- So, jetzt sind wir fertig
mit dem Patienten.
Dann haben wir dann noch die
Dokumentation. Ganz wichtig.
- Das ist seine Mappe?
- Genau, richtig.
Wir haben unter drei
haben wir die Leistungskarte,
die ist ganz wichtig, weil die rechnen wir
nachher mit der Krankenkasse
und der Pflegekasse ab.
Genau,du siehst hier die Leistungen,
die sind schon geplant.
Genau, wir würden uns dann hier
quasi einfach nur eintragen
mit Uhrzeit und Handzeichen, dass wir
diese Leistung erbracht haben. Ja?
Und du siehst, hier steht wirklich
jede Leistung drinne,
die wir auch erbringen.
- Alles, was wir beobachten,
sollen wir hier [auf]schreiben.
- Genau, alles was so außergewöhnlich ist.
Wenn der Patient sagt,
er fühlt sich wohl, alles ist gut,
dann muss das hier gar nicht
drinne stehen, weil davon gehen wir aus …
Wir haben heute Morgen den
Herrn Hombach, Ihren Vater, versorgt.
Der ist super motiviert, hilft mit.
Man muss zwischendurch
immer Impulse setzen,
weil er das dann auch kognitiv nicht
umgesetzt kriegt, aber ansonsten …
- Ja, das ist das Schwierigste
für uns eigentlich, ja.
Sie machen das auch immer prima,
seit Sie da sind. Das ist wirklich toll.
Also, wir haben da manchmal
solche Probleme,
aber das ist wirklich eine super Hilfe.
- Sehr gut, das freut uns doch zu hören.
So, Frau Hombach, wir sehen uns morgen.
- Tschüss, Herr Afarsiou,
vielen Dank für Ihre Hilfe.
- Gar kein Problem.
- Das ist echt Klasse,
tschüss, Patrycja. Viel Spaß noch.
- Vielen Dank, bis morgen.
- Ich freu mich.
- Tschüss.